Programming models are fundamental specifications that define
how software is structured
and executed they provide a framework
for developers to express all gritters
and organise cold often obstructing away low level details
of the underlying hardware or execution well
different models are suited to different types of problems
and hardware detectors offering
varying levels of obstructions
and control in this chapter
will review quantum and classical programming models
and see how we can combine them to operate all greater
in hi
will start with the programming model
for a quantum computer one fundamental programming model
which is familiar to almost all quantum developers
is the quantum circuit we won't go
into the detail of quantum circuits
here as we already have many great resources
including a lecture by joan waters
will only mention that the circuit is built out of
a set of lines called wires which represent cubits
as well as gates which represent operation on quantum states
and a set of measurements
another important programming model concept
for
this primitives represent the most popular tasks
that users tried to accomplish with the quantum computer
there are two primitives available at this moment
simpler and estimator simpler gives you the ability
to sample a state prepared by quantum circuit
and estimator lets you estimate the expectation value of
an observable for a system in the state prepared by your quantum
circuit the final concept
we're going to talk about in this section
is transportation transportation
is the process of writing a give it input circuit
to much the apology of a specific quantum
device
for execution on noisy quantity computers
similar to classical compilers
a transcallation routine gradually changes
the structure of the circuit by a playing set of passes
now let's talk about classical programming models
there many programming models
for classical computers
but in this chapter will focus on to
the boss popular parallel programming
and task workforce by using this two models
incombination with quantum programming models
one can express pretty much any hybrid
quantum classical workflow of any complexity
the better programming model
divides a program into some problems that can be executed
at the same time there are two main paradigms of parallel programming
shared memory perilism and distributed memory paralysm
for our purposes here let's focus on distributed memory model
a distributed memory model
uses independent processes on separate course
or notes where each process has its own memory
and communication happens using message passing there
a few concepts that will be useful to know
the first is the process
which is independent instance of the program
running on a separate core
also the rank which is a unique identify of the process
and then there is single program
multiple data obstruction model
which is an obstruction model
for computation where a single instance of the program
is distributed to multiple notes
so the source code is the same
but the date on those notes are different
the execution and peril programming model
happens in the following way
a single program distributes to multiple notes
and starts multiple parallel processes
the control for of the program is dictated by the rank
or the identifier of the process
and communication happens
through message passing
a task workful programming model
obstruct computation intergraph or deck
where each note of the graph is a particular task
or job and edges of dependencies data
and ordering examples can be found in our documentation
after all the sequence that we're always talking about in quantum
computing mapping optimisation
execution and post processing
is a task workful programming model
where all tasks are executed one after
another in the pipeline
but with task workflows
we're not bound to sequential execution order
and can execute tasks in parallel
each task or work flow can be an entire parallel job
of its own so you can mix
and match this models to describe all greater
of any complexity.
Let's try applying some of the concepts that we learn
to cold first will try to run simple hello world
using parallel programming paradigm
we're gonna be using open mpi
which is the implementation of npi protocol
which is the sender for message passing
in parallel programming
first we need to have our program regime
here where using mpi for by
which is bite and binding
for npi and as you can see where using ground here to decide
the control flow of the program
so let's check our submission script.
As you can see we're gonna be using two notes
one task per note in normal partition
and let's crown our program we're gonna moit a bit
and we can check results of our job
as you can see who have log outputs of our program
here we use two notes and two processes
which are identified by a rank
as you can see here as an output
rank zero in frank one which used to decide
the control floor of our program
is you can see ring zero process sent
some pay load to the rank one process
and rank one process accepted
dispay who also talk about task war force
there are tools that called work
for management systems they're specifically designed
to run complex workforce
but to not overload you were going to be using built in
dependency feature in slow
to construct those computational groups
first we need to have tasks of power work
for ready this is the same cold
the benefit of having each of this tasks
as mapping optimisation execution
post process as a separate steps
is that we can specify unique resource requirements
for each of the tasks for example mapping optimisation
postposing does not need
access to quantity resources
therefore we can run them on classical partition.
But execution task will need
quantity resources therefore we're going to run it on quantity
partition.
Let's now you slearn dependency feature to chain tasks
into warflow.
As you can see was still running
our as better comment with flag possible
which will return the job i d
and then we can pass this job idea
as a dependency to other tasks
for jobs as you can see what running
jobs in the workforce with the dependency
once the entire workflow is complete we can check the results.
And is you can see what have our extra fishing value back.
And we also can check all of the
results from each of the steps.
Which are also here.
And that's it for the programming model section
in the next chapter we're going to be talking about adventural
gritters